everyone watching this already made a
decision this morning
this morning they made it a
life-changing huge decision this morning
and that is either i started a few years
ago doing what i call priming
and what priming is most people can't do
that at all because it's just too
painful yeah they have all these
messages back here that says you're no
good and you can't be
beside you your makeup isn't on right or
you forgot to shave today or something
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn that 10
hard choices that you need to make in
your life
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with choice
number one flip your insecurities with
david goggins
every day in my life i'm haunted by my
father
the kids that bullied me my own
insecurities
all these things were just this this
roost in the back of my head
so i'll be driving home at like seven
o'clock in the morning
from all night shift and all alone in my
truck
and i'll be thinking what the [ __ ] man
my life is hell
so one day i came home i was and i
always come on watch tv
and this show was on with like navy
seals yeah
and i'm afraid the water terrified the
water i sink like a rock so i'm sitting
there watching these guys going through
navy seal training
and i'm like and i saw what
what i believe how look how a man should
feel
very you know have pride and dignity
himself yeah so i gotta change myself
so literally i sat down on the couch and
watched these guys going through seal
training
and i went through my own mental
checklist
of how [ __ ] up i am and how many
things i would have to change
just to get an opportunity to try out
for something like that
have to get smarter have to get fit have
to lose weight have to
do all these things start running
swimming everything
so i finally get to a point where um i
get the courage
to go to a recruiter and say hey i want
to go try to do this but when you're 297
pounds and you're gonna go try to be one
of the fittest people in the world
yeah you get laughed at so i got laughed
at a lot
but in this process this process was
actually hardening my mind
all the laughter because the laughter
used to make me cower
now i realize i can no longer hide from
my insecurities
high from all these fears i just started
wearing them yeah had to start talking
about how to start being vulnerable
because i was always afraid of them so
here i am now
i'm facing them i finally find a
recruiter that says hey we'll take you
in
and he says you have less than three
months to lose 106 pounds
i'm like that's you know that's possible
so
that was my mindset i was like hey i
can't have that kind of mindset
so i went to the dungeon and started
using all my insecurities
as strength instead of looking at being
bullied and
and uh my dad messing me up and all that
stuff like that i looked at it as
who could have survived all this and
still be here with the opportunity
to go into navy seal training and so i
started using all these negative things
and started flipping everything on top
of his head instead of saying what was
me
kicking rocks head down in the dirt i
started saying there's not a
on the planet who would have this
opportunity coming from where i came
from
they would be a statistic yeah so i
started looking at it as power
versus like big time defeat and slowly
but surely
every day i started changing the voice
in my head because the
the most important conversation you will
ever have
is the one you have with yourself choice
number two change your thoughts with
brendan burchard
your life doesn't end up an accident
your life
is a series of actions that you initiate
or don't initiate
and that your thoughts are going to
control that roadmap
and so how are you using your mind today
to either make yourself feel great or
not
i posted on instagram this morning i
said listen your destiny is ultimately
controlled to
by a decision you already made this
morning everyone watching this
already made a decision this morning
this morning they made it
a life-changing huge decision this
morning and that
is either i'm going to get up
enter the world with no intention go
through the motions to hopefully get by
or survive
or i am going to get clear in this
morning
about what i want what i'm going after
who i'm going to be
how i'm going to serve and whether or
not i'm going to be excellent and
extraordinary
or not and the problem is most people
never make that conscious decision
so and so i was learning early on make
the conscious decision about who you
want to be
each day stay congruent with that
and that was you know for me a kid who's
just going through the motions all of a
sudden going oh
who do i want to be what do i want my
relationships to be like that was really
important
and then i started setting personal
challenges every month at the beginning
of each month
i do this whole thing where i
holistically evaluate my life on the
first of every month
and it's like these 10 different
categories of my life you know from
emotional to relational to financial to
um you know career mission objectives
all these things
i go down that uh on the first month
just kind of holistically point in my
life
and then i set a personal challenge and
a professional challenge
and i do that every month every sunday
i revisit my progress every sunday for
23 years
so it's not like i'm just you know
one day ended up in a happy life it was
like that a level of self-evaluation
that most people avoid
until their birthday or new year's i do
it every sunday and every first of the
month
and i don't ever miss and i think that
has helped me kind of know
what my thing is because i don't think
i'm
super special choice number three ignore
the opinions of
others with j shetty when you fake being
someone for so long
you think it's your reality and that's
what happens to all of us we play a role
at work we play a role at home we play a
role with our family we play a role at
our friends
and then we think that role is us right
and we lose ourselves
and to me that is the core reason why
we're chasing things that are not
important to us
we're unhappy despite reaching accolades
and we feel dissatisfied so what should
our identity be then
our identity should start with
unlearning
everything that we think we know about
ourselves okay how do we unlearn
so the best method of unlearning is this
first and i'm gonna get really strategic
and tactical because i think that people
need to know what to do rather than a
concept
the first thing you do is write down
everything you currently are chasing in
your life
make a little goals your dreams your
goals your dreams published
anything that you're currently chasing
and pursuing okay write them down
you can write down three equations five
you can write down 10 depending on how
ambitious you are
second line ask yourself what is the
source
of that where did you get that idea did
you get that idea from
a tv show you saw did you get that idea
from your parents did you get that idea
from
your mom and your dad your sister your
cousin did you get that idea
because your friend just got proposed to
on instagram did you get that idea
because your friend just got promoted
did you get that idea because you just
broke up
right or did you get that idea because
you just feel it when you do it that you
feel alive
give me a specific example that you had
when you were 15 18 was like a goal or
accomplishment that you were chasing
and where it came from absolutely so my
my goal when i was young was to be an
investment banker and when i really
asked myself where did that come from it
came because
in my community small community in
london
the most successful person financially
was an investment banker
so i believed you had to be an
investment banker to be successful
right so when i asked myself that
question where does that come from
it comes from society's version of
success not mine
and then the third thing you ask
yourself is well then what is mine
what is coming from inside of me and if
you just do that three-step process
now what you're doing is you're
filtering out the noise and you're
starting to listen to your voice the
thing is you've got a voice inside of
you but
it's quiet it's like it's like jay like
take note of me like lewis
you know and it's just like trying to
get through and the noise of everyone
else's opinions is so loud
so this way you filter it how do we
start to find out what we truly want
then
not based on what other people think is
success how do we how do we listen to
ourselves and
if you've been chasing something your
whole life how do you say well actually
that's not what i want
this is yeah one of the biggest mistakes
we make is that we confuse inexperience
with being unqualified so because we've
not tried a lot of things
we just naturally believe that we can't
be that good at them
so if i've never spoken on a stage i
just think oh i'm probably not good at
that
or if i've never played golf i'd
probably think i'm probably not good at
that
and so we start writing off things
without even trying them
so the best method i can share with
someone is take the next
month take the next four weekends in the
month that gives you eight days
and get really tactical every single day
that's why you're playing tennis a lot
right now yeah
take the eight days go join a course an
online course or workshop go and shadow
a friend go to a seminar a conference go
to
reading a book listen to podcasts go and
expose yourself to eight different
things in a month eight different things
eight different things in a month
and guess what in a month you will have
learned what you probably would have
learned in eight years because most of
us test one new thing a year
maybe maybe if that exactly right like
some people don't even do that but if
you do eight different things in a month
and this is how you have to see it if
you went to eight different restaurants
in a month
you ask yourself after you eat a meal
like i had that burrito or i had that
taco
did i like it right the first question
you asked yourself is did i gotta try it
first you gotta try it first you gotta
go to the restaurant yeah there's no
point so you're gonna say did i like it
the second question you ask yourself is
why did i or why did i not like it
like why is so important i think too
many people just go i like it or i don't
like it why didn't i like
and the third question you have to ask
yourself really really simple is do i
want to do it again
and if you do that's where you start
uncovering is so my point is
inexperience do not misinterpret
inexperience for a lack of qualification
i'm guessing you're doing things in your
life right now that you would have
written off
if you didn't try everyone i have been
reading a bit from my friend's book evan
carmichael built to serve and i wanted
to share this with you
so according to a study by carnegie
mellon university
people with supportive spouses are more
likely to give themselves
the chance to succeed they studied 160
married couples and found that people
with supportive spouses
were more likely to take on potentially
rewarding challenges
those who accepted challenges
experienced more personal growth
happiness and psychological well-being
now i can truly say that i've
experienced that in my life when i first
met my wife
i was just starting out i had never
released a video
i hadn't created any content and she was
such an important part of feeling
supported on that journey so
whether you're in a relationship whether
you're dating whether you're married or
even if you're single
being supported by friends and a strong
community is important
uh build to serve by evan carmichael
great book
on how you can find your purpose and
also on reminding us that we can all
make a difference in the world
thanks evan choice number four be
vulnerable with brene brown
i think it's really all of us i think
the majority of us were raised
with the belief that vulnerability is
weakness um that it's best to armor up
when we wake up in the morning go out
into the world
don't put yourself out there don't let
yourself get hurt
um really stay
closed um because it's not worth the
risk it's not worth the criticism it's
not worth
you know we have this program called the
daring way where we train coaches and
therapists in our work and
one of the exercises we do is we put up
this big poster that says
vulnerability is and then participants
fill out a post-it note about how they
would finish that sentence stem
vulnerability is
and then we all look at that and so
there's tons of them that will say
vulnerability is weakness
vulnerability is showing too much of
yourself but one of them just struck me
the other day and it said vulnerability
is the first step to betrayal
and so it's showing enough of yourself
that someone could use it to hurt you so
we all grew up with this myth
that vulnerability is weakness but
what's interesting to me
and what i think is the source of a lot
of the problems today is
we were also mostly raised to believe
that it was important to be brave
for sure so here you've got this thing
where vulnerability is weakness
but you need to be brave and courageous
so really the only thing that can fit
through that gauntlet of you can't be
vulnerable but you need to be brave
is bravado is that kind of blustery
um posturing kind of fake bravery and i
think that's what we see in the world
today
um i think what we see and i'm not
talking about badassery like the good
stuff that you can back it up
sure i'm talking about if i can't be
vulnerable but i have to be brave
what's left except to fake being
tough and i think the way we fake being
tough and our culture today
is we're super cynical we're super
critical of other people who are putting
themselves out there
we make fun of things that's how we fake
bravery
but the truth is if you you know when we
asked people in the research
what is vulnerability they said things
like
i mean i remember sitting across from
someone who said
it's sitting down with my wife who has
stage four breast cancer
and making plans for our young kids
it's calling hospice and having a
conversation with them about my dad
it's the very first aid i went on after
my divorce
it's trying to get pregnant after my
second miscarriage
vulnerability is never easy and it feels
terrible but there's no
evidence that it's anything but courage
i mean
the best example i think and something
that i think everyone in here and
everyone watching can relate to
is picking up the phone and making that
call after something horrible happens to
someone we care about yeah
right and we look at the phone and we're
like i really need to call i can't
believe her husband dropped dead he was
45
i just you know what i'm gonna call in
an hour she's probably resting
and then an hour goes by and then you're
like you know what she's probably got
family over for dinner i'll call
tomorrow
and we just keep are you in my brain
right now yeah right now i know
i mean it's it's it's human nature and
then
but the question is what happens when an
hour turns to a week
turns to a month and then we run into
that person at the grocery store
and we haven't called like what does
that feel like for us
it's shame yeah it feels shameful it's
shame it's shaming
but what happens when we just pick up
the phone and go
there's nothing i can say to make this
better except i love you
i care about you and i'll walk through
this with you
and then when we hang up from that call
we know we didn't fix anything because
there's nothing fixable about that
situation
but we feel in line with our values
we feel like i did the courageous right
thing authentic self the authentic self
and it's not about how this makes me
feel it's about making the call
so to me i think the most profoundly
dangerous
myth is the idea that vulnerability is
weakness
i just there's no evidence choice number
five
make that decision with bob proctor what
are the ideas should we we should be
saying to ourself internally and
actually well i think you have an
affirmation a positive statement from
yourself you give to yourself
and that has something to do with your
goal you know
um that's how you change the paradigm
the paradigm can only be changed one of
two ways one is an emotional impact
which doesn't happen often and the other
what's the example for that what's uh
well an example for that would be 9 11.
yeah now 9 11 wasn't an emotional impact
for me
it probably wasn't for you but for
people that lived right near
there or lost somebody there that was
emotional impact
just something that hit you so hard yeah
it just knocks you off your pins
emotional impact and repetition
constance-based repetition
see you take this affirmation of thing i
want to change
um and you've got to keep repeating it
to yourself you've got to keep seeing it
through the repetition of it
pretty soon it becomes fixed in your
mind then the thing you're afraid of
becomes a habit you just automatically
do it yeah like there's things you do
automatically
today that you don't even give a thought
to
but at one time you're afraid to do it
sure so that's
i think that's how you keep changing
thought is a very powerful
thought is the preamble to everything
thought waves are cosmic waves they
penetrate all time in space
um i had a good fortune working with ed
mitchell he was the captain of the lunar
nan
landry module one of the apollo flights
and he did thought
transference exercises from the other
side of the moon wow with the
sherman and ford here on earth they're
all gone now
but you're doing thought transferred
exercises all the time
and we just have not got to a point we
really understand that
like if i um here's my phone
if i dial your number i'm on your
frequency
i will never get tiffany's phone to ring
all right and let me get your phone to
ring
if i take a picture of tiffany and i
send it to a friend of mine
in singapore simultaneously with me
hitting send here in los angeles
they've got it in singapore you know
that yeah
thought works the same way i could be
thinking of you
i'll trigger cells in your brain and
your cells
if you're not thinking those cells will
start jiggling you'll start thinking of
me
and maybe i'll phone you and say that's
a damnedest thing we're just thinking of
you yeah how was all the time
well we got to understand what's
happening you think on frequencies
now this has to do with goals when you
set a goal
you have to flip your brain onto the
frequency that the good that you desire
or that you need for that goal is there
so you you you most people don't make
the decision because they don't know how
to get it
you don't have to know how to get it
that's why von braun said when kennedy
asked me how to get to the moon
the will to do it you're going to make
the decision you don't make the decision
when you've got enough money or when
you've got all the resources
you make the decision when you make the
decision you flip your brain onto a
higher frequency
and then you're on the frequency you
begin to attract everything on that
freak that's where the law of attraction
comes in
see the secret brought out the law of
attraction but it didn't explain it none
of them explained i didn't even explain
it you didn't get the time
most people don't even understand it you
can only attract according to the
frequency that you're operating on
attraction is a secondary law the
primary law is the law of vibration
that's a that's a primary law of the
universe everything in this room is
moving nothing rests
this table's moving it just appears to
be still
the law of vibration decrees everything
moves nothing rests
well when you think you put you under a
frequency
you can only attract what's on that
frequency you think about a person a lot
just concentrate
that personal from you or you'll bump
into them on the street
because you you're thinking about it
yeah the law of attraction takes over
you can attract to you what you're in
harmony with well when you set goals
you're going to see yourself already
there that's called a mindset
a lot of people talk about mindset they
don't understand what it is they
set their mind on the frequency that
they have to be in
to attract what they have to attract
and that's how the gold moves into form
you get emotionally involved you're
you're so intellectually and emotionally
involved the only problem is you don't
have it on the physical plane
yet but it will manifest in time choice
number six
practice gratitude daily with tony
robbins
gratitude it's incredible what gratitude
does the two things that mess
everybody up are anger and fear when you
let them dominate you you're in trouble
and you can't be angry and grateful
simultaneously
the antidote it's the only answer that
really works and you can't be fearful
and grateful simultaneously
so for me to answer this question i
don't hope i'm going to be grateful i
have a system like anything in life i
you know if you're a great pilot you
know how to fly a jet you still have a
checklist
because if you miss the checklist the
consequences are too big so i'm not a
big
meditator my meditations have been
active it's been physical it's been in
nature it's been ripping things open
it's being on stage but i started a few
years ago doing what i call priming and
what priming is
is most people think their thoughts are
their thoughts when really your thoughts
have been primed by the environment
that's why you want to create the
environments like ukraine and i create
because it makes you be your best
but specifically there's a study where
they took a group of actors they had
them go out to 200 people
and the only thing different they walked
up each person and the only difference
was they held a half cup of coffee
they walk up to your stranger go do all
this for a second they look down so you
can't say yes or no
and you'd end up taking it they get
their phone they adjust it they take it
back and say thank you
that's the whole thing same facial
expression for every person only
difference
half got an iced coffee the other got
hot coffee
now 30 minutes go by they send out an
assistant a research assistant with a
clipboard and they come up to these same
individuals and say
if you give us two minutes your time
we'll give you twenty dollars will you
just read these three paragraphs
and tell us what you think of this
character a couple questions
they read the three paragraphs and they
say what do you think of the main
character in this little story
81 percent that were given iced coffee
say the person is cold and uncaring
eighty percent a one percent variance of
those are hot coffee so the person is
warm and connected and caring
with nothing else but coffee 30 minutes
earlier ice cold
i could tell you 50 of these so what i
do is i get up every morning and i make
a radical change in my state and i have
a simple deal with myself i prime for 10
minutes every day
because if you don't have 10 minutes you
don't have a life there's no excuse so i
come in
i do this radical breathing change these
three sets of 30 breaths when i
bring the air in and explode it out my
nose because you know i'm sure you know
from eastern philosophy
the the breath is like the string on a
kite the mind is the kite
you can change the mind through breath
so i do this radical breathing takes
a minute then i do three things for
three minutes really simple i say three
minutes and i focus on three specific
individual things that i'm grateful for
but i don't think about them
intellectually i step into the moment
remember it feel it and just and so what
it does is it activates it not as
thought but as a biochemistry then i do
three minutes of prayer and blessings
starting with my family and moving out
to everybody my clients friends people i
meet
and then i do three minutes on what i
call three to thrive where i focus on
three
important outcomes that i have that i
want to accomplish but i don't think
about one accomplishment i see it i feel
that experience is done i feel grateful
i offer that's your move i i actually go
15 or 20 minutes around because it feels
so good but what's happened is now
you're
primed you're not hoping you're in prime
time you are in prime time
and to me that's how i do it and once
you prime yourself you start noticing
things to be grateful for all the time
and when i asked
sir john templeton where the first
billionaire investor international
investor in the whole world started with
nothing built to that
i asked him i said what's the secret to
wealth i'll never forget he looked at me
and smiled and he said tony it's what
you teach
i said i teach a lot of things which
thing and he goes gratitude
choice number seven challenge yourself
with mark cuban
what was going on what conversations
were you having in your head or your
parents or who
that you said as a junior i want to take
business classes i just think i've
always been wired that way
you know when i was 10 years old i was
taking baseball cards and repackaging
them and having a little
trade show for baseball cards in the
local park um
i was selling garbage bags door to door
you know get basketball shoes when i was
12.
um i was buying and selling stamps when
i was 15 and 16.
um i i don't i don't know i i think
i think um as much as anything
i've always been very very competitive i
like to create these funky challenges
for myself
um and so i decided that my first two
years of college i was going to take all
the hard classes
and not drink so that by the time i was
a senior in college
i could party like a madman and say
freshman english okay and so i went to
register for
senior level business classes and
realized that okay i could take grad mba
classes
they didn't know that but i just stood
in line and registered for these mba
classes
got in and did well um i mean my
freshman year my
my first year semester at iu i took
graduate level statistics and i thought
okay if i can you know do well in this
class i can do well enough
i got an a in it choice number eight
stop being
a victim with gary zhukov answer this
how do you react when everything is
going wrong and life seems unfair
maybe you are frustrated and angry
because you did not get the raise
you felt you deserved or the job you
were qualified for
or maybe you were left with nothing
after your marriage ended or
you're one of the many women who has
struggled for years to get pregnant or
even
to find love and get married and you're
still looking for mr right and all the
wrong ones keep showing up in your
opinion
well gary zukov is here and gary says he
has some information for you today
that how you choose to respond to the
difficult and challenging things
that happen to you really does mean the
difference
between living the rest of your life
bitter angry and resentful or
living your life with joy gary of course
is the author of seed of the soul
and soul stories which is now on
paperback and he is back to tell us what
to do
when life seems unfair you say that when
you believe life is unjust
you are declaring yourself a victim and
that it makes your life even more
painful
that's right yeah this show brings us to
the heart of spiritual development
this show is at the core of what life on
the earth from my perspective is about
and that is stepping into a genuine
responsibility for who you
are what you do and what you contribute
while you are on the earth
becoming a victim is resisting your life
now do not misunderstand me resisting
your life does not mean
contributing things to life or simply
being a doormat to the world
resisting your life means not looking at
your life realistically the way it
is and then moving forward
from there to the extent that you resist
your life
you become yourself a victim you say
this shouldn't be happening to me this
is unfair
it's not the way i want the world to be
and it's not the way i believe the world
should be and as you do that
you lose power now the question becomes
how will you walk on the earth
the choice is yours and i am not
suggesting that there is anything
morally or ethically
wrong with looking at yourself as a
victim
or in any other way what i am suggesting
to you
is that you consider the possibility
that everything that happens to you in
your life
is an opportunity that allows you
to expand into a fuller potential and
powerful and meaningful life choice
number nine
have a pristine place within you with
maya angelou
there's a place in you that you must
keep
in violate you must keep it
pristine clean so that nobody has the
right to curse you up
treat you badly nobody no mother father
no wife no husband
knows nobody because that may be the
place you go to when you meet
god you have to have a place with did
you say stop it
back up not he must not
no no absolutely and that's one i told
you
25 years ago yes say no when it's no
yeah say so back it up because that
place
has to remain clean and clear
and that has to be a place within you
yes ma'am when the person comes with
rude language to you or
invasive language to you you have to be
able to say
back up not mean you don't
i'm don't you know i'm a child of god
and choice number 10 the last one before
a very special bonus clip
is let go of the past with louise hay
if you're going to clean a house you
have to see the dirt
you know if you're going to clean a
turkey pan if you're going to do the
dishes you have to see the dirt that
you're cleaning
and then when you do that then you can
do lots of good mathematicians
even though i have whatever the problem
is i love and forgive myself i accept
myself i destroy myself where i love and
approve of myself
yes right off if the that's to me like
the mirror work that i do
we'll have people do it also is to look
in the mirror and look into your own
eyes and start with something really
simple but difficult like i love you i
really really love you and most people
can't do that at all because it's just
too painful yeah they have all these
messages back here that says you're no
good and you can't be in
besides your makeup isn't on right or
you forgot to shave today or something
you know
but once you can do that if you do it
over and over again for a while
it's like you connect on a different
level with that inner child
who's been waiting for years and years
and years for you to acknowledge it yeah
a lot of us just want to stop
when we hit a safe place yeah i mean
you've got a bit of money you've got
some nice friends you have a good house
to live and you're okay
you know and you think all right that's
fine i'm not going to touch anything
else
but i have watched me and how life works
for me is that when i get to a really
good level
then it's like okay now we're gonna deal
with this thing yeah
and there's another thing and i've
learned to just say okay what do i do
now i've got a very special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i wanna know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you get
motivated inspired you have a 35 chance
of following through but when you get
motivated inspired and you create a plan
of action
you have a over 90 chance of following
through
and when you share with other people it
jumps to 95
chance your likelihood of following
through and so i want that to be you
from this video we don't just watch
videos here believe nation we do
something we take action
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate you the
fastest way to change your life is to be
around the people who
think like the way you want to think
through videos
podcasts books courses mentorship
events and so on get obsessed with being
surrounded by your heroes and they will
pull you into the world that you want to
be living in
otherwise you stay exactly where you are
so i used to read a lot of books every
day i used to read a lot a lot a lot
because it was the only way to learn
because
i realized that for me to get from where
i was at to where i wanted to be
it wasn't going to come from the people
around me right now
my parents or my heroes they're on the
wall behind me here i'm
you know eight or nine in that picture
and they taught me how to be a human
they gave me values belief comes from
them
but in terms of being an entrepreneur
that's not their skill set that's not
what they are i don't want to be an
entrepreneur like my parents because
they aren't great entrepreneurs and so i
recognize that for me to get to where i
want to be
in entrepreneurship i need to be
surrounded by other people who are doing
and thinking
the things that i want to be doing my
youtube channel i make selfishly for
myself
i love learning from all the people that
i profile on all of my channels
because i need it for myself because
they pull me up elon musk is a
fantastic example because anytime i
think like i'm thinking big
anytime i feel like i'm doing amazing
things i'm unstoppable i'm untouchable
i go to someone like elon musk and think
man this guy here is trying to
have a backup plan for humanity in case
we kill ourselves
we can all go to a different planet and
then i realized man i'm not thinking big
at all i'm just being the big fish in a
small pond and i think that's good i
think you need that i think you have to
be around people
who are pulling you up to the world that
you want to live in you find people who
are exactly
doing the thing that you want to do and
then be around them more and you'll just
naturally start to think like them act
like them
have the mindset like them and move
towards living in the world that they're
living in
okay how do we do it how do we hack our
learning style to learn from people
who've done what we want to do
and they will pull us from where we are
now to where we want to go three steps
let's go
step number one is understand your who
what is your who who i break it down and
build the serve
you're who is your single most important
core value what is it mine is believe
right
what is it for you understanding what
your single most important value
is gives you clarity gives you roadmap
gives you that compass
to help you make better decisions for
the rest of your life
if you constantly feel like you're being
pulled in a million different directions
everybody wants you to do something and
you're not sure for yourself what you
should be doing next
is because you don't know what your who
is it's one of the single greatest
exercises you can ever do as a human
being
figure out what your who is to give you
that roadmap of clarity or
life step number two is identify which
three people are living the best so if i
look at
believe who is living the best who is
doing the thing
that i want to do and a lot of them are
here on the wall right i got
steve jobs i got my favorite
entrepreneur of all time ipa giannini
and i've got my parents and even in here
is a great
model right my parents taught me to
believe as a human what is
what is what is believing as a human
looked like uh
ap giannini brought that to
entrepreneurship and he bet on
entrepreneurs when nobody else would
would believe in entrepreneurs
he lent money to hardworking immigrant
entrepreneurs based off of a handshake
and a look in their eye if you can
imagine that and he went on to found
bank of italy which later became bank of
america
and then steve jobs talking about having
a vision and believing in your ability
to go make a dent in the universe
right these are three people or in this
case
you know a couple where i wanna emulate
different pieces of
and so identify for you who are three
people who are living the life that you
wanna live even if they're not alive
right
thankfully my parents are still here but
these two have long passed that's okay
dead or alive which of the three people
who are thinking the way that you want
and then set number three is how can you
be surrounded by them daily how can you
be around them
every single day because your
environment right now is keeping you
where you are
your environment right now is not
pulling you to the place that you need
to be
this is how insanely valuable strategy
it is to help build you
to the person that you need to be you
have to be around these people every
single day
even if they've passed on so i can be
around elon musk even though i've never
met him i can be around steve jobs even
though i'm never going to meet him right
same thing ep janine they can be around
him he's a little more difficult because
there's no content on him uh that's
that's
in video form which i love so i am
reading his book i've got his ebook that
i'm reading
but i can be around him every single day
think about your physical environment
right they're they're here
on my wall i'm consuming their videos
i'm reading their books
slowly every day their thoughts their
mindset the way they think and process
the world
is seeping into me to make me stretch
and grow and get slowly to where i want
to be because again
your environment is just keeping you
where you are right now all the people
that you've been around all the books
and and media that you're consuming all
of it is keeping you where you're right
now
and this channel is helping you pull a
little bit forward and start taking
inventory of the things that are
actually pulling you forward
that when you finish watching and finish
reading or finish hanging out with that
person it makes you want to be better
it makes you want to do more it makes
you want to strive for a greater life
than what you've got right now
and then incorporate that every single
day into your life
your life will change
if you want to know the 10 universal
skills that are hard to learn but will
pay
off forever check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you talk to people who are
expert computer users they are so bloody
powerful it is just beyond belief
trying to build a company and have it
succeed is like eating glass and staring
into the abyss